[Music]
have you guys checked out twitter
recently
nah i haven't been on people because i
got a twitter not that much on twitter
like twitter like maybe once a week
neither it's like angry politics
no you have an account wait where's
titties on twitter a lot a lot
a lot of cam girls really yeah there's a
lot of the wrong people dude whenever i
go on i just see ryan's eggs that's all
i ever see
that's true i know what's up with ryan
all you posts are eggs
he just posts like videos of frying his
eggs yeah ryan the guy who's in there
oh really the only thing he ever tweets
is just him
frying eggs it's just a video it's being
fried that's it there's got to be some
kind of social commentary in there
for something nope bouncing titties i
don't know
yeah it's really odd and then i always
think that maybe he's talking over it
but i just scroll past so i never really
like no
you click on it and all you hear is
sizzling
well we have to find out next time uh
comes on here i thought twitter was just
like rants
or like that's pretty much what it is
pretty much okay
yeah i mean they now extend go at it
with people just on text
i believe it is uh yeah that's what i
heard so i was like i'm on twitter
yeah so do you even have anything no no
i don't have twitter at all
nothing it's a good platform though
right i mean the best platform for
getting cancelled yeah
that's why i got off of it dude that's
last name for raging like people just
raging out
like they just they just complain that's
what i heard yeah
but you also do find a lot of funny
memes on there there's some goals in the
comedy world there but anyway
comedy wise it's pretty good yeah yeah
it's only that
yes i agree nice well twitter recently
debuted
their new fleets function which is
pretty much
just instagram stories which is pretty
much snapchat
which is pretty much just kidding no but
like every single social media
platform is just copying each other left
and right
it's a new tool where you can execute
somebody with your words now oh
[ __ ] that would be crazy mortal kombat
finish them yeah
you know what i missed remember back in
the aim days you could like punt people
yeah it's like a bunch of like random
code things that you could do to [ __ ]
people's life
up yeah but you can't really like you
know what that is we need to punt people
you could you could sign them offline i
can like punt you and you'll sign you
off like how do you do that
it was this day and age like let's say
you go on your instagram i'll sign you
off your instagram
over and over and over and over and over
again so um is there like a code
you can get that idea you can paste the
code or people would create
like programs where it would do the code
for you and then so you remember aol the
instant messaging thing
so most people they had um dial up right
like they had to go on the 56k
modem and then you send it through their
uh instant messenger and then it signs
them off
oh really yeah yeah that's crazy and
there's all kinds of different ones but
like
this day and age i think they're so well
programmed you can't just go on twitter
and like scramble signed off yeah like
you can't just scramble someone's
profile picture like there's all kinds
of weird [ __ ] you can do well there is
there was that one
bully laments like the change of
technology
that was bullying old school huh oh [ __ ]
yeah we didn't call it that though it's
called
fun that was online bowling i remember
that day when we had to choose if we
wanted to have a phone or internet you
can't have both at the same time oh yeah
that was crazy i do miss that sound
though
yeah you call into your friend's house
and then you hear that sound you're like
oh he's on aim right now i can't call
him
oh really you heard it yeah because you
get the busy noise yeah yeah
i remember that yeah i remember signing
on the internet
yeah and then my mom picks up the phone
to call her grandma or her mom and then
just signs me off too that's why you
needed two phone lines
you needed two phone lines what people
had two yeah i didn't have that
that sounds fancy yeah you had a phone
line just for the internet
or the fax machine because it was
connected somehow damn you guys were
rich
i didn't i never even had no we had one
we only have one
[Laughter]
yeah um yeah but the whole the so
recently i do remember
in like the past few years that there
was this text message that you can send
to people and if they had iphones it
would like [ __ ] up like hack and [ __ ] up
their entire phone yeah really
yeah there's like a newer version of
that man how can we [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
like that again i miss doing that
i figure you you can figure it out
because i used to be a hacker no
but like whack ones things right like on
uh ig
right now they'll dm you hey you want
this and you click it and then it messes
you up right
or they can hack your thing oh we got
this gift for you
yeah are you the guy are you the guy who
thinks he won something oh never never
but you they get like people that follow
you or
like like they hack them first yeah they
hack then
send a message from someone you know and
then like hey my
my phone got hacked like that wasn't me
sending it like what the hell you sent
me some weird [ __ ] you know
yeah and then i was like no it wasn't me
so yeah they'll hack like that's true
someone that does it maybe someone that
is your friend that has like 500
followers not that many
get in easy hack you dm you from them
until you
you know so that happened to a lot of
people
remember that one where everyone got
hacked and their twitter their youtube
like everything got hacked oh yeah
it's crazy like they hacked like one
server that had all those accounts
on it or something oh yeah i remember
that that's crazy like all of like
the youtube titles are getting renamed
yeah all of that remember that
it was crazy i was crazy i got hacked
because my password was abcdefg
three passwords that's not technically
hacking dude
do you think that there's people that
actually have the password because
they're like man that password is just
too easy no one's gonna think i have it
i don't have it for long because the way
that passwords work now they're like you
have to uppercase
lowercase some kind of a symbol
character that's so small they won't let
you just write passwords
forget that password quick you got to
write it down one uppercase
one symbol one number yeah i hate that
annoying that's why i like it now and
they just generate it for you like
oh the apple stuff yeah super strong
password
but anyway back to fleets so i'm gonna
show you guys a video
where they are showing you how to use
fleets
on twitter and it looks just like
snapchat uh
yeah pretty much damn man that's crazy
so you see you go to your twitter and
then you see a tweet here
and then you could go here and then you
could go share
in fleet oh so you're sharing you're
just sharing with words
you could do that or you could like type
your own [ __ ] or you could take a photo
or video literally stories
instagram stories so just like in
instagram how you can share your own
posts
to your stories that's pretty much what
they're looking for in their face you
know what tells you all
about instagram is like you got your in
feed video you got ig tv
and you got reels and all three stories
oh yeah and it's also it's all different
huh did you guys notice how they changed
the format now and like you try to click
on one thing but now it's reals are you
trying to put shop on top i don't like
that reels is what's hitting though
down there you get a lot of views on
reels never i never like
really do it i don't like how it looks
or whatever but that's what they push is
the reals like
you see on your feed yeah you'll put a
reel from like
two weeks ago to make you watch someone
else's reel out double tap and i'll feel
like a dick like
you know what i'm saying like i didn't
even see this and it's like from
you know october and i double tap like
it has a dick he's going back liking my
[ __ ] i don't know you know
but you don't know because it's probably
seemed like you're a weirdo
teasing yeah it seems like you're a
weirdo too like i scrolled down
i you know and i picked this one and i
liked it
but really they popped it up on my you
know news feed i feel like because of
the fact that
it's no longer chronological order a lot
of people understand that
oh yeah i posted this two weeks ago but
i know the algorithm didn't just show it
to you until now what about the people
that like
every single one of your picture and
then you check out your feed one day and
or like um
your activity thing and it's all just
one person oh cause they're trying to
get your attention brother
no but like it's weird um i feel like
people mostly dudes do that too right
dudes with hot girl pics
[Laughter]
horrible i got a couple friends that uh
get catfished by that
ah horrible be careful look at this and
and they'll get mad they'll say like you
don't think i could pull girl like that
like i'm not saying that
but i am saying that of course i'm
saying that i'm a big model
are you [ __ ] stupid of course i'm
saying that
they got like three pictures yeah no
comments
yeah i feel like people who are trying
to blow up though they get like i've
seen people who are
like in the middle of growing their
platform and then somebody likes like 20
of their photos back to back
and then they'll post in their story
going like oh thank you so much blah
blah like people are
they like that excited about it yeah
people are really happy yeah
but what about if it was a childhood
friend that you don't talk to anymore
and then you check your feed and they
spent the last six hours
liking every single one of you he's like
i'm showing you that i want to connect
again
[ __ ] this guy he's crazy creepy that is
crazy right
i don't know well you just told him
because he'll find this
maybe he yeah hey [ __ ] you man
he's all over your [ __ ] he'll find a
dick you guys are dicks
but you know another annoying thing that
i realized that instagram did too is
that
because they're pushing reels so much
the real like
reels so it's when it's in your feed and
you're watching a reels
clip and you're trying to make sure that
you watch the whole thing but then it
ends up ending and it says like click on
the button to
click unreal is that reals or is that
like igtv
no id tv is better because igtv actually
has the timeline
thingy where you can scrub through it
and then they pick and once you pick
that i mean once you click on that
button
to go to ig tv it it still plays from
the part that you
left left oh my god i can't speak left
off on
right but when it's reels and then you
click on that reels button it restarts
the reel
so you have to restart the whole [ __ ]
thing again i'm like why are you doing
that instagram it's so annoying so
to bypass that little hack to bypass it
if you see
if you see a video that you want to see
the reels like the whole reel click on
the button before it ends
and then it will show you the video from
the part that you started watching
instead of re-watching it does that make
sense i hope i got it do you think you
introduced a problem i didn't even know
i had and you fixed it for me yes
yeah i got you back i got your back do
you think that
uh cause you watched you used tik tok
right no i thought you liked tik tok
no i did and i liked it so much i got
scared so i deleted it
but during that time do you think that
reels made up
for the lack of you know how they're
trying to everybody's just reposting
their tick tocks
yeah like no one's really creating
original reels content
you got tickets are sponsored i mean i
have one but i'm not an active one have
you ever had a friend that you're just
like
oh i like you too much i'm never talking
to you again yeah ah
no because i've never had a friend that
takes up all my time like i see
tick-tock damn how much time was
tick-tock taking is watching dances or
what
no like she's watching booty shake
videos i just addicted
that algorithm is so good where it
happens instantly it knows
what the [ __ ] i like already what do you
like creepy
i like the bad dances when people are
like trying to figure it out though
no i like watching animal stuff or
comedy stuff or like satisfac like you
know like uh
oddly satisfying stuff oddly shiny i
thought
you were watching mad twerk videos
non-stop yeah dance videos huh you know
me i'm a savage i like the tick tocks
where people are like i
this lady next door she's alone so like
i'm a good person i hung out with her
for
10 minutes what a loser yeah but they
like they put they put like
inspirational music behind it and make
themselves look like the best person
i hate those i don't like that i don't
like that at all
i like the mr beast kind of videos which
one of those ones mr v
well he's not even i don't know if he's
on tick tock but he just he just makes
giveaways or what yeah yeah
like he um yeah i don't like those
either no but his is funny like he'll be
like
he'll be like um i bought a whole entire
dealership
and then he dresses like a dealer and
when people come in he'll be like all
right
this car is 20 and then they're like
what and they're like all right all
right fifteen dollars
no that's funny but like for me
personally i don't like consuming like
uh real life
uh experimental things like pranks
or oh yeah yeah like personally i i
don't consume that
personally i like to consume big mood
content yeah personally
i don't like to just kidding
[Music]